kids are not Commodities to be bought
and sold people are not
property children have rights the reason
this issue has come up recently is that
same-sex couples have begun to purchase
children through surrogacy and invitro
fertilization liberals celebrate this
novelty most conservatives find it
instinctively abhorent but even some
self-styled conservatives celebrate it
the reason for this unusual degree of
confusion and controversy is that the
issue is entirely new nothing like this
has ever happened before in human
history the reason for that is
twofold first our political order has
for the first time in the history of
civilization denied the necessity of
sexual difference to marriage that is
our system of law has for the first time
ever denied the difference between men
and women the second reason is
technological for the first time in the
history of the world we can create and
gestate human life outside of the
conjugal act for the first time ever we
can make babies without
sex unfortunately technology and
ideology have outpaced bioethical
inquiry to quote Jeff gold blum's
character in Jurassic Park your
scientists were so occupied with whether
or not they could that they didn't stop
to think whether they should actually
the full quote is even more RT than
that in that full quote gold Bloom's
character says quote the lack of
humility before nature that's being
displayed staggers me he describes the
scientist's actions as a violent
penetrative act that scars what it
explores entirely true and in the case
of IVF and surrogacy what the discovery
here both technologically and
politically explores and scars is people
specifically innocent little babies the
case of homosexual men purchasing
children through surrogacy is
particularly and most obviously
egregious because it involves creating
babies with the express intent of
denying them their mothers the bond
between babies and their mothers is the
most intimate bond that human beings
will ever experience the mother is the
very environment in which the baby forms
the mother's voice is the first voice
the baby ever hears mother and child
share nutrients that sustain them both
before and after
birth many children grow up without
mothers for all of history motherless
has been a rare and unfortunate event in
a fallen world that leaves a wound to be
healed as best as it can be today mother
less is an intentional political program
undertaken with the blessing of the law
which now holds holds that the presumed
right of men to Children trumps the
actual right of children to their
mothers sadly this phenomenon though
recent has now occurred for long enough
that we can read the accounts of
children who lament the trials that
accompany this unnecessary
hardship the writer Katie fa has
detailed such anecdotes in the
Federalist the biological hardships to
begin children who are conceived through
surrogacy and IVF face more health
problems they tend to be born premature
and underweight worse still though are
the psychological and spiritual problems
Envy of their friends with mothers the
hatred of Mother's Day the pressure not
to express their anguish even because it
might make the men who raised them sad
the social adjustment issues the
difficulties bonding with the
non-biological father the identity
issues the constant wondering about half
siblings the existence of whom they are
legally barred from knowing The
increased risk of depression The
increased likelihood of being prescribed
anti-depressant drugs the total neglect
of their reasonable suffering by a
society more concerned with stamping out
imaginary phobias than with protecting
the natural rights of children the basic
Universal longing of children for their
mothers because moms and dads are
different it's ghastly it's absolutely
horrific it is just about the most
rotten thing a society can possibly do
to the children but many many who have
opined on this issue want to place blame
just in one corner and I unlike them do
not I do not even really blame the
homosexuals it's very easy to look at
the situation and accuse these adult men
of selfishness and they are selfish
obviously they put their own desires
their natural desire for children along
with their disordered desire to exclude
women from that process
ahead of the rights and interests of
their prospective children but I suspect
that most of them don't know that in
their defense these men have been told
by the entire culture for about 60 years
now that men and women really aren't
different and if men and women really
aren't different then moms and dads
really aren't different and if moms and
dads really aren't different then why
would anyone need or even want to have
both of them what's the difference
between a family and a couple of fellas
if that premise is
true I don't mention these harsh truths
to make the men who have fallen for this
lie and temptation feel bad about
themselves I don't suggest that we take
away their children that we might
Endeavor as best we can to introduce
these children to their mothers this is
a Fallen World there is no way to undo
the terrible crime that has been
perpetrated on many people the children
most of all of course but even the men
who were told that they were doing
nothing wrong
the men who sincerely believed that and
who might now be listening to this
speech thinking in horror wondering what
have I done it's a terrible feeling
we've all made mistakes some more
egregious than others but there is no
sense in trying to undo the past there
is no sense in dwelling on past sins
after we've seen the error of our ways
the reason I mention all of this is to
stop the crime from spreading to prevent
this from happening again in the future
I do not primarily blame the homosexual
men for the growing evil of surrogacy
and IVF I don't blame the women either
we all know the statistics about
children who grow up in fatherless
households the significantly higher risk
of behavioral problems of going to
prison of abuse and neglect of drug and
alcohol abuse and so on kids need their
fathers it isn't complicated at some
level every single person knows that I
do not primarily blame the homosexuals
of either sex for this awful situation
they are simply following a 60-year
series of delusions that our culture and
politics have promoted to their logical
conclusion the primary culprit I believe
in this case will likely surprise my
critics the culprit is
capitalism more precisely the culprit is
capitalism unconstrained by morality and
more precisely still the culprit is the
commodification of children of people
broadly and children in particular
before I came here tonight I was told
that the Democratic Socialist Club of
Clemson had planned a
protest there was going to be a big
protest but then it was a little chilly
outside that was enough and they said
ah I don't know even with a code on it's
a little too cold so if they were here
had they protested they they might be
surprised by my thesis perhaps they
would have given me a hero's welcome but
probably not right I don't think they
actually would have done that the reason
they wouldn't have is that they love
this kind of stuff the left loves the
commodification of people the Socialists
here do not actually hate capitalism
capitalism is a word that was
popularized by Carl Marx himself okay
ironically the Socialists who pretend to
hate capitalism actually love it in as
much as capitalism makes everything
including people about money just as
ironically the conservatives who purport
to love capitalism actually hate it in
as much as we know that life is about
much more than money the left might
worship Mammon we do not what we
actually love and what we call
capitalism but what we're actually
talking
about is morality which entails the
protection of things like property
rights but which recognizes crucially
that people are not
property we outlaw slavery because we
recognize that people are more than
property to be traded we Outlaw the sale
of organs for the same reason a true
free market absolutist the most extreme
kind of capitalist might endorse the
orgon trade reasonable people however
recognize that it is probably wrong to
harvest the organs of the poor I think
we all generally would agree on that
right yeah this is the same reason we
Outlaw
prostitution the true free market
absolutist sees no problem with
prostitution most people however
recognize that it is wrong to entice
poor women in terrible circumstances to
sell their bodies as meat we recognize
that people are more than property free
markets can be a wonderful thing I love
the free markets don't get me wrong I
was sucking up to the Democratic
socialists for a second here they're not
even in the
room free markets can be a wonderful
thing in the words of Pope John Paul II
quote the free market is the most
efficient instrument for utilizing
resources and effectively responding to
needs but efficiency is not morality and
human beings are Not Mere resources to
be
utilized human beings are the subjects
for whom resources are
utilized capitalism circumscribed by
morality is as fine a method for
producing material Prosperity as has
ever been discovered capitalism
unconstrained by morality is a
monstrosity as efficient and instrument
as ever but efficient in the degradation
of people by denying their very humanity
and the rights that go along with
it this ultimately is the problem with
IVF and surrogacy the chief problem with
IVF and surrogacy is not that the icky
gays use it as some selectively outraged
critics would seem to suggest the chief
problem with IVF and surrogacy is that
it commoditized human life when a man
begins the process of the sort of IVF
and surrogacy that we've been talking
about he first opens up a catalog and he
picks a woman he would like his child to
have blonde hair so what does he do he
flips to the blonde section of the women
catalog remember they went after Mitt
Romney for the binders full of women
here that was metaphorical here we have
literal cataloges to buy women so they
they find the the blonde section of
women and then the man says that he
wants his kid to be smart so he's going
to need a Harvard graduate now I would
never choose a Harvard graduate if I
wanted but he doesn't he doesn't know
he's very confused so he picks a Harvard
graduate and look there might be an upch
charge for that sure that's okay though
this man he's done well in his career
and he's more than willing to pay to
make sure his child never suffers the
indignity of having to go to Brown or
something like could you
imagine then of course he's got to make
sure that woman has no disabilities
that's completely off the table if he is
going to Shell out this kind of money
and we are talking about $100,000 easily
maybe more than that well he doesn't
want to have to deal with any
imperfections earlier this year two
homosexual men wound up suing the
surrogate that they had contracted to
gestate a child for them they sued her
because she had been diagnosed with
cancer and they found out that the
medical treatment might cause birth
defects with the child that sounds bad
enough right it's that sounds like they
wanted her to forego medical treatment
so that she didn't harm their baby right
it's actually much much worse than that
the men sued the surrogate because she
refused to kill their child or one of
their one of the men's child through
abortion the men did not fear that the
medical treatment would harm the child
enough to kill him they feared that the
medical treatment would not harm the
child enough to kill him they feared
that the treatment would harm the child
just enough to give him a disability and
then they would have to accommodate that
disability and they didn't pay for that
they feared that their designer baby
would not come out perfect which would
be inconvenient but they also didn't
want him to live because they didn't
want their quote DNA out there that is a
direct quote
so they demanded that the surrogate kill
the baby they had paid for him after all
they had rented the woman's womb
whatever happened to the customer is
always
right last year another couple of men
filed a lawsuit this time against a
fertility clinic and a specialist
because these men had ordered two baby
boys but you know what got delivered a
baby boy and a baby girl they didn't
order that when I order a box of cigars
and I receive the wrong box you know
what I do I send it back for a refund I
want the cigars that I want that's what
I do I would if if I got some other kind
of cigar I would send it back that's how
it works with all of the products that I
purchase and if people are now products
then that's how it's going to work with
people
too but people are Not Mere
products products don't have rights
people do babies included in fact it is
precisely because babies have rights
that adults cannot claim to have a right
to them many people today fall into the
error of believing that they have a
right to a child even some conservatives
fall into this error but it's
Preposterous in making that claim
actually they undermine their own
argument because if people have any
rights at all then no one can have a
right to another person a child is not
something that is owed to someone but it
but rather a child is a blessing a gift
that one is
given a child is the Supreme gift of
marriage not everyone receives that gift
many married couples struggle with
fertility and it is incredibly painful
it is a terribly difficult cross to bear
but the alternative to that cross is
even more terrible and that is the
treating of children as property to be
bought and sold rather than as people
with rights in the matter of procreation
the only person who possesses genuine
rights is the child those rights include
the right to his mother and father and
the right to be respected as a
person so far we have only discussed the
many ways in which IVF and surrogacy
violate the rights of the child who is
born we have not yet even touched on the
children who are not born because IVF is
so expensive in many cases many human
beings are created sometimes many
embryos are implanted at once and
sometimes lots of them stick at which
point doctors advise mothers to have a
reduction of the number of
embryos they they will reduce quote
unquote the embryos to a more
comfortable number that is a euphemism
by which they mean the killing of some
of the children in the mother's womb so
that she only gives birth to one child
maybe two instead of two two children or
maybe three who knows even if the mother
chooses not to abort any of the children
that have been implanted that usually
still leaves a number of of embryos that
is of human beings of people sitting in
a freezer and sitting in the freezer is
how they will remain if the mother
doesn't want any more children human
bodies and souls on Ice until the
patient or clinic decides to kill them
what about the cases in which all
embryos created through IVF are
implanted into the surrogate and none
are aborted in that case we still face
the problem of ripping a baby away from
the surrogate that is to say the woman
who is the nearest person to a mother
that he has ever known the voice that he
has heard his whole life short life but
his whole life the woman who will carry
his DNA in her body for the rest of her
life we use clinical language such as
surrogate and gestational carrier I'm
not kidding that is from one of the
lawsuits that I just mentioned
gestational how does that make you feel
ladies you're a gational carrier sounds
like a a piece of military
equipment that's the kind of
dehumanizing language that plaintiffs
use in these lawsuits we use this kind
of clinical language but the bond
between women and the babies they carry
is permanent we know this because
scientists have discovered male DNA in
the brains of women after their death
which seemed kind of strange on account
of how men and women are different but
this led the scientists then to discover
that the DNA was from the children that
they had carried in their WBS that is to
say that babies literally physically
remained a part of them for the rest of
their lives but then what about the
cases in which all the embryos created
through IVF are implanted none are
aborted and no surrogate is used this is
without question the case that most
people consider to be the most
acceptable of all and still here we Face
the same fundamental problems IVF and
surrogacy even in the most publicly
acceptable case do something that we
have never seen before in American
history they establish the domination of
Technology over the orig and Destiny of
the human person they entrust the life
and identity of the babies into the
power of doctors and
biologists this trust is not merited we
seem to read stories about this at least
once a year now just last year a
California woman sued an IVF clinic for
implanting the wrong embryo into her
whoops the woman gave birth to someone
else's child one supposes that another
woman gave birth to her child child now
whose child is whose this was not a
one-off incident earlier this year a
North Texas couple sued a Fort Worth
fertility clinic for using the wrong
sperm to conceive their children through
invitro
fertilization bigger oops huh in the
case of the California couple perhaps
they could trade the baby back to his
rightful parents whoever they might be
strange as it is to say one might think
of a solution
in that bizarre case in the case of the
Texas
couple what is anybody supposed to do
the doctors just created a baby whose
parents are not married whose parents
did not intend to create a baby together
whose parents are married to other
people what are those adults supposed to
do more importantly more horrifyingly
what is that poor baby supposed to
do it's ghastly no one who gives this
matter sufficient thought can seriously
defend this dehumanizing process and yet
and yet there is one final argument in
favor of ibf and surrogacy and it is the
most persuasive argument of all
precisely because it is not an argument
the argument is that there are many
people today who owe their lives to IVF
and surrogacy some of my friends were
conceived this way many people owe the
existence of their own children to IVF
and
surrogacy a number of my friends and
many of my acquaintances have done it
and what those parents instinctively say
to any criticism of IVF and surrogacy
any look that's a little bit too close
into the details is they will say
without IVF and surrogacy my kids
wouldn't exist so damn your arguments
damn your bioethics I don't care where
your reasoning leads you I support IVF
that's what they say and it's completely
understandable that is a totally natural
reaction because kids are good kids
conceived through IVF are just as good
and have just as much a right to life as
kids conceived the old-fashioned way of
course but good ends do not justify evil
means no end no matter how good
justifies immoral means a child
conceived in rape is just as good as
children conceived in marital love of
course he has just as much a right to
life as a child conceived in any other
way but his goodness and his right to
life do not therefore justify rape we
still discourage rape we Outlaw rape
without rape that child would not exist
and the child is a blessing but rape is
obviously wrong so we Outlaw
it there is no contradiction in that
sentence a friend of mine is fond of
observing that fact acts do not care
about one's
feelings you may know this
friend now I have pointed out to this
friend of mine that while facts might
not care about feelings politics almost
exclusively cares about
feelings and we are feeling creatures
that's part of what makes us
human but our feelings can deceive us I
am not the first to observe that the
imagination of man's heart is prone to
evil from his youth even the best of
intentions detached from the rigors of
logic and the constraints of morality
can go terribly wrong the road to hell
is paved with good
intentions modern technology can Dazzle
us ideological fads can hypnotize us but
Eternal truths remain whether we wish to
acknowledge them or not people have
rights which means that people are not
property which means that kids are not
commodities